[Musik]
95 prozent aller entscheidungen die wir
treffen treffen wir unterbewusst quasi
auf autopilot die richtigen klamotten
kaufen wir nach gefühl zähne putzen wir
aus gewohnheit und auf dem weg zur
arbeit fragt sich keiner ob man jetzt
nach links oder nach rechts abbiegen
muss oft sind es positive dinge die den
autopilot macht wie zum beispiel
zähneputzen ohne darüber nachzudenken
häufig sind es aber auch negative zb in
jeder kleinen pause plötzlich sein handy
oder eine zigarette in der hand zu haben
ohne sich bewusst dafür entschieden zu
haben
nichtsdestotrotz ist es eine gute sache
dass wir so viele entscheidungen
unterbewusst treffen weil sonst wenn wir
damit ziemlich überfordert aber was wäre
wenn wir wüssten wie diese
unterbewussten muster entstehen und
diese sogar komplett umprogrammieren
können was wäre wenn wir den autopilot
ecken würden und ihn dazu ausnutzen von
ganz alleine ohne dass wir uns dazu
überwinden müssen die richtigen dinge zu
tun die uns glücklich gesund und
erfolgreich machen wie das gehen soll
und ob das funktioniert finden wir in
diesem experiment heraus indem ich euch
zeige wie ich genau das versuche in
diesem video werde ich euch ein komplett
automatisierte system vorstellen für
hausaufgaben arbeit studium journal im
tagebuch to do list kalender aber auch
private sachen wie essens planer
bücherliste und film listen dafür werde
ich hauptsächlich meine sagen wir mal
notiz und planungssoftware benutzen die
mein team und ich jetzt schon seit
anderthalb jahren verwenden es ist
ungelogen der heilige gral was das
projektmanagement tools und notizen
angeht weswegen ich auch schon 55
menschen die in irgendeinem einer teams
sind weitestgehend freundlich davon
überzeugt habe das auch zu nutzen damit
ich da eben all meine projekte
organisieren kann und da ihr diese
software in videos hier und auf meinem
zweiten kanal ja auch schon häufig zu
gesicht bekommen habt wo ich dann auch
ein- zweimal gebracht wie die den hass
es ist nun schon okay ich benutze motion
so jetzt ist es raus und ich kann hier
mit auch voller stolz sagen dass dieses
video einfach von motion unterstützt
wird damit habe ich natürlich auch
dieses video geplant und ihr könnt zu
kostenlos benutzen also probiert doch
gerne mal über den link in der
beschreibung aus vielleicht wollt ihr
auch euren autopiloten hecken warum
genau für mich da seit anderthalb jahren
deutschen alternativlose ist später
jetzt kennen uns erst mal die frage wie
man sein auto club überträgt dafür
definiere ich zuerst was positives
verhalten ist zum beispiel sport machen
aufräumen konzentriert arbeiten und
tägliche tagesplan danach definiere ich
was negatives verhalten ist wie zum
beispiel progression ihren zucker essen
teams schauen und später aufstehen
anschließend wird für jeden punkt
infrastruktur schaffen die dafür sorgt
dass es
da ist positive dinge zu tun und
negative dinge nicht zu tun aber was
meine ich eigentlich mit infrastruktur
doch wohl keine straßen und
wasserleitungen oder doch eigentlich
schon stellt euch mal vor ihr seid
bundeskanzler eines noch nicht so ganz
entwickelten und schlecht vernetzten
landes und wollt dass die bürger also
deine tüchtigen arbeiterbienen jeden tag
pünktlich in der fabrik erscheinen sich
weiterbilden fleißig sind und zwar nach
ihr geld ausgeben damit die wirtschaft
angekurbelt wird jetzt kann man sie
natürlich einfach dazu zwingen hat man
auch oft versucht aber viel effektiver
ist als infrastruktur zu schaffen die
dafür sorgt dass den menschen das
verhalten dass du von ihnen haben willst
so leicht fällt dass sie ohne widerstand
einfach mit dem strom gehen sprich
straßen um zur arbeit zu kommen
kostenlose schulen für bildung oder eine
stabile währung damit das gehalt auch
nächste woche noch etwas wert ist und
diese straßen können wir auch in unserem
alltag bauen damit wir nicht jedes mal
widerstand und überwindung spüren
sondern im klose ein kleines beispiel
ich habe sehr häufig meinen schlüssel
verloren der eigenen wohnung untersuchen
dauert eine ganze weile und hat schon
oft dafür gesorgt dass ich immer zu spät
kommt dieses stück infrastruktur also
nein verraten neben der haustür sorgt
mittlerweile dafür dass ich ihn einfach
jedes mal automatisch daran ich finde
jetzt also immer direkt und kommen zu
spät einfach weil es mir jetzt viel
leichter fällt das positive verhalten
den tag zu legen die schlüssel immer
dieselbe stelle zu packen das errichten
der infrastruktur in dem fall also
dieser einfach erhalten hier hat kaum
zeit und geld gekostet zahlt sich aber
jeden tag aufs neue wieder aus und
dieses prinzip lässt sich auf alles
anwenden
lasst uns also infrastruktur erstellen
damit zum beispiel das verhalten
konzentriertes arbeiten in zukunft ganz
von alleine geschieht in motion kann man
ganz einfach jeden einzelnen unterpunkte
in eine eigene unterseite verwandeln in
die ich dann rein gehen kann um dort
weiter zu planen zunächst definiere ich
alle reibungspunkte also dinge die es
mehr schweren fokussiert zu arbeiten
ablenkungen energiemangel
überforderungen und mangelnde überblick
sind die hauptpunkte die ich mit einem
größer zeichen ganz leicht ein und
ausklappbar mache denn manche davon
bekommen unterpunkte die jeweils einzeln
angegangen werden müssen und da wird
sonst schnell unübersichtlich nun
braucht es für jeden reibungspunkt ein
system das das problem automatisiert
lösen wir wollen ja nicht ständig an
alle punkte denken sondern eben einmal
zum beispiel einen schlüssel hacken
kaufen der die reibung dauerhaft
beseitigt
der hauptgrund warum ihr konzentriertes
arbeiten oft schwerfällt ist mangelnden
überblick zwischen all meinen projekten
tomato marie lol dinos chapman p.geo ein
schnittkurs und natürlich auch noch
privat welche aufgabe ist wirklich
wichtig was muss als nächstes erledigt
werden schaffe ich das überhaupt der
deadline wohl auch noch gleich der
zettel die notiz das dokument rum dass
ich jetzt brauche und die beiden
effektivsten methoden das zu lösen sind
erstens ein zentrales notiz system das
reibungslos funktioniert ohne dass man
jedes mal stift und papier aussuchen und
dass am ende alles noch irgendwie
sortieren muss und zweitens eine gut
durchdachte to-do-liste beziehungsweise
einen taskmanager in dem alles
organisiert ist für sich selbst und auch
für die leute mit dem man zusammen
arbeitet ist damit man den ganzen tag
nicht ständig alle sachen im kopf schon
gehen muss deshalb hab ich auch schon
auf windows android ios also auch ein
tablet handy und pc direkt im
schnellzugriff dass ich zu keinem
zeitpunkt nach meinen notizen zu suchen
sondern direkt alles eintragen und mit
abrufen kann und wenn man jetzt noch
einen draufsetzen will braucht man sich
ein system dass beides zusammen verein
aber wie meine ich das was meine ich mit
baut wie bereits erwähnt ist die lösung
zum hacken des autopilot infrastruktur
und systeme die dafür sorgen dass das
gewünschte verhalten einfach so ließ und
motion ist nicht nur ein to do oder
notiz programm das man genauso verwenden
muss vorgegeben wie ihr das trend kennt
man kann den deutschen wirklich alles
bauen wie man es will und dadurch
infrastruktur und workflows für seine
eigene produktivität oder sogar ganze
unternehmen maßzuschneidern wie eine
selbst designte websites durch die ihr
euch durch klicken können und euer team
natürlich auch sofern es habt und ja das
funktioniert auch für minecraft server
richtig gut ihr müsst dafür kein
unternehmen haben wir unserem server
projektor ing sind da sogar 40 leute zu
gange
alles besteht aus diesen blogs die man
jederzeit verwandeln kann aus einem
einfachen text werden stichpunkte eine
checkliste eine überschrift ein zitat in
farbe ich kursiv usw einen blog kann
einen screenshot sein denn man einfach
mit steuerung v einfügt und blogs köln
angeordnet werden wie man möchte in der
kostenlosen version kann man unbegrenzt
viele dieser blogs erstellen und bis zu
fünf gäste in den workspace einladen um
mit ihnen zusammenzuarbeiten unbegrenzte
gäste und file uploads gibt es für unter
vier euro monatlich und den teams plan
mit allen features und per vision system
gibt es für unter acht euro pro mitglied
pro monat und jetzt kommt mein lieblings
blog der unsere notizen und to-do-listen
so lud revolutioniert die datenbank ich
erst einmal eine in form einer ganz
normalen tabelle erstmal das besondere
hier ist dass es jede spalte eine
eigenschaft haben kann wenn die to do
list könnte das hier zum beispiel eine
checkbox sein die ich einfach mal fertig
nenne checkbox kann man es hier abhalten
kann man natürlich brauchen wir auch mit
deadline und dafür verwenden wir das
format datum die priorität wir mit einem
so genannten select ausgewählt kann
jetzt mal spiel nehmen oder medien oder
high oder europa 9000 und die einfärben
oder auch so an wie ich es gerne hätte
da ich noch mit anderen zusammen arbeite
hier natürlich noch eine person rein dem
hineintragen kann und dann nochmal weil
sie hier eine auswahl für das projekt
ist desto mehr es ist mein zweiter kanal
meine app zum beispiel fertig so einfach
war es so jetzt sagen wir mal ich will
ein zweites video machen über 3d drucker
und zwar möchte ich dass das gerne
übermorgen erscheint es ist mir extrem
wichtig und ich hätte es gerne von paul
geschnitten ich selber muss natürlich
aufnehmen dass wir beide eingetragen und
das gehört zum projekt comrie 0 1 2
kanal und schon ist die to do
eingetragen und jetzt beginnt die magie
aber dafür stelle ich dass wir noch ganz
viele verschiedene aufgaben
[Musik]
so werde jetzt eine liste mit ganz
vielen tattoos das sind sachen die
einfach anfallen manchem datum manche
sind sehr wichtig bei manchen arbeitet
damit bei manchen arbeitete dann wird
das ist zum beispiel bei mary das ist
hierbei ein zweiter kanal und so weiter
und so fort aber das ist aktuell noch
mega unübersichtlich also sortieren wir
das letzte bisschen einerseits wird hin
wird es natürlich nach priorität also
wichtig ist ganz oben dann sortieren ist
aber auch noch nach dem datum und jetzt
kann ich folgendes machen weil ich will
ja nicht immer alle aufgaben aus dem
ganzen team sehen sondern vielleicht nur
die sachen die ich selber machen musst
also stelle ich hier meine ansicht die
nächste thomas und da mal jetzt ein
viertel an wo der zugeteilte mich
beinhalten muss
john sehe ich jetzt nur noch die sachen
wo ich auch wirklich drin steht paul zum
beispiel in der 2
er will natürlich nur sachen sehen die
auch wirklich mit ein zweiter kanal zu
tun haben also viel mehr nachkomme
reloaded und dann will er natürlich auch
nur sachen sehen wo er wirklich auch
selber was dran machen also fehlt mir
auch noch nach ihnen und schon haben wir
die sachen die er machen muss sortiert
nach wichtigkeit jetzt kann man diese
sachen hier einfach abhaken werden
natürlich noch viel schöner wenn die
abgehackten sachen gar nicht angezeigt
werden also macht man filter der alle
sachen automatisch ausblendet sobald sie
abgehakt werden
und schon ist es fertig und diese
kapelle kann jetzt auch einfach als
kalenderansicht betrachten wenn dann das
zum beispiel lieber ist oder hier im
board you can dance teil den er
vielleicht könnten hier kann man auch
einfach alles hier herumschieben wir
sind alles die gleichen informationen
wieder angetragen haben nur in einer
anderen sichtweise in meinem deutschen
workspace in dem auch mein team ist gibt
es ebenfalls eine zentrale datenbank in
der alle teams und notizen von
sämtlichen projekten einfach so
aufgelistet sind aber das ist nicht zur
eigentlichen verwendung gedacht wir
haben stattdessen in jedem projekt eine
eigene datenbank die mit dieser masse
datenbank verknüpft ist nur jeweils mit
speziellen auf das projekt
zugeschnittenen filtern eigenschaften
und sortierungen bei mir sind diese
projekte zum beispiel max lipp deinem
skype und co und bei euch könnte das
sony web-entwicklung videoschnitt oder
haushalt seien dadurch hat man die
übersicht dass in jedem projekt gleich
die passende to do liste ist und man
neue aufgaben direkt dort erstellen kann
wenn man sich er bereits im projekt
befindet aber durch die master datenbank
habe ich nun auch die möglichkeit
einfach direkt in meine notizen aufgaben
zu erstellen ohne dass sich dazu extra
ins entsprechende projekt navigieren
muss das klingt jetzt also eine
kleinigkeit aber genau das macht das
notizen schreiben so viel zentraler und
leichter dass es fast automatisch
passiert einmal das handy öffnen nur mit
einem tab bin ich ready und somit hat
diese infrastruktur die welt erstellt
haben das thema notizen
aufgabenverteilung und damit
konzentriertes arbeiten reibungslos und
gerecht für die produktivität auf
autopilot
ich versuche jetzt auf diese art und
weise auch noch jeden anderen aspekt
meines lebens zu automatisieren und
zeigt euch dann wie so ein perfekter tag
auf autopilot aussehen könnte um 7 uhr
wird aufgestanden meine morgen routine
nimmt mir hier das denken ab da es mir
leichter fällt videos und andere inhalte
auf social media zu teilen und dieses
positive verhalten dadurch
wahrscheinlicher wird wenn ich jeden tag
geduscht bin dusche ich mich
mittlerweile nicht mehr kalt sondern
warm was die fiction aus den duschen und
damit aus dem video produzieren nimmt
was soll ich heute anziehen ist eine
frage die ich mir nicht stellen muss
eine gewohnheit dass bereits abends zu
tun übernimmt dieses problem frühstück
mochte ich noch nie und kostet mir
unnötig willenskraft und zeit also lasse
ich das mittlerweile aus und nennen es
einfach intervall fasten und so bin ich
bereits pünktlich um 7 uhr 30 pünktlich
am rechner und mit der arbeit anzufangen
da ich bereits gestern den heutigen tag
geplant habe kann ich direkt loslegen
ein video zu skripten wozu ich mich auch
nicht zwingen muss da ich in einem neuen
template bereits wichtige
rahmenbedingungen und routinen definiert
habe die dafür sorgen dass ich eine
konkrete checklist mit konkreten
aufgaben abarbeiten kann und nicht vor
einem übermächtigen und undurchsichtigen
problem steht der gesamte tag kann
natürlich nicht wie einen morgen routine
getaktet sein aber für alle möglichen
wiederkehrenden aufgaben habe ich eine
effiziente routine geschrieben beim büro
aufräumen stehe ich also nicht vor der
frage wo fange ich an
zuerst gestehen die küche tragen müll
aufräumen herumliegende klamotten in die
wäschekörbe equipment an seinem platz
bringen und dann die oberflächen
abwischen immer genau in dieser
reihenfolge auf autopilot nach einem
produktiven arbeitstag der sich nicht
nach arbeit angefühlt hat bleiben wir
noch einige gedanken ideen und toulouse
im kopf die ich nicht mit in den
feierabend nehmen will deswegen mache
ich wie ich es nenne einen brain damp
bei dem ich den ganzen inhalt meines
kopfes einmal in meinen leicht
zugänglichen notizen aufschreibe und
dann vorerst entspannt vergessen kann
diese liste wird kurzerhand ab arbeitet
mit datum und angabe des projektes und
der mitarbeiter und schon ist der
nächste tag wieder geplant also so ein
produktiver tages zumindest das wovon
ich nachts träume ganz so glatt läuft
sind leider noch nicht aber ich arbeite
dran und ich habe richtig bock menschen
das alles organisiert große schau dort
übrigens an thomas frank von dem habe
ich sehr viel über menschen gelernt von
dem und aber auch von außen direkt gibt
sogenannte templates wissen vorlagen die
ihr euch einmal kopieren und selber
verwenden können und probierten auch
schon unbedingt mal über den link in der
video beschreibung kostenlos aus glaubt
mir ich habe fünf jahre lang alles
getestet und motion
am 29 6 und findet zum ersten mal
lauschen sie virtuelle konferenz für
europa starts bei der ihr sehen könnt
wie kleine und große unternehmen notion
komplett ausreizen den link dazu findet
ihr natürlich auch in der beschreibung
und damit will ich sagen vielen dank an
ocean für diesen sofort aber vor allem
dafür dass ihr so ein geiles tool
entwickelt hat und in diesem sinne
abonniert gern main kanal und dann sehen
uns nächste oder übernächste woche
wieder macht's gut
[Musik]